you and i both know about the armenian
and the assyrian and the greek genocide
you know 2.2 million people total you
know we read about it you're seeing
what's going on right now with
azerbaijan and and armenia
the the the the atrocity that they're
bringing down and erdogan is supporting
in the same we have to finish what we
started
yeah they're nazis islamic nazis
it's it's it's terrible what's going on
there so
that's two and a half 2.2 million lives
you have the holocaust that took place
41 to 45 you know say 6 million lives
you have slavery that took place for for
many years
and that was millions of lives oh no no
wait a second
what slavery slavery 400 years of
slavery where
in america owning a slave was legal
excuse me
that's a big leftist lie not that you
left this or are aware of it obviously
correct me it's okay what would you say
it is first of all
and that and that and that is the heart
of the project to destroy america
led by the new york times which is
the gravity of the situation we're in
the 1619
project 400 years
uh includes english colonies america was
created
in 1776 as a matter of fact the times
claiming that there were 20 slaves
imported into virginia
is a is a lie they were indentured
servants
and and slavery was outlawed in virginia
in 1619. um
america was 168 years away from being
created
it was created in 1776 with a
revolutionary proposition
that all men are created equal and have
a god-given right to liberty
from 1770s actually america wasn't
formed until
1787. but from 1776
to 1863 the emancipation proclamation
is 83 years and if you go from 1787
it's less it's 70 whatever 72 years
that's the extent of slavery in america
starting in 1776 the northern states
freed their slaves
they were freed by 1804 the slave trade
was abolished by 1808.
why didn't the northern states why did
they make a compromise with the south
because the south was very powerful we
almost
lost the civil war when it was fought 70
years later
the south would have aligned with the
british
who burned the white house in 1812
and slavery would have you know who
knows how much longer it would have
lasted
america gave 350 000
mainly white lives to free
the slaves and the life of a president
who was assassinated because of it
the reality is
black africans enslaved blacks sold them
at auctions in ghana and benign
and white americans freed them
the democrat party is a racist party and
the whites in it
are self-hating rights to attack america
to allow
al sharpton to give the eulogy the
the number two racist in the country
sharpton
a convicted liar uh who never paid by
the way
the people that he libel the let this
demagogue
talk about 401 years of america having
its neon the next of blacks
america liberated blacks blacks and
slave blacks
that's the reality and the the
duration of slavery in america is a
little over maybe two generations
at that point in time fair enough
two generations too long is that a fair
estimation to say two generations too
long
okay things don't change over no we
barely won the civil war in 1816
1862-5 slavery is not america's
original sin it's america's original
virtue
that that clarion call for for freedom
all men are created equal and have a
god-given right to liberty
has affected people all over the world
and
and liberated them and the fact that the
new york times
and the left and the democrat party
would want to trash this country's
history
the private uh you know of its sources
of
self-pride and self-worth
shows how dangerous the democratic party
is and why i call it a communist party
as part of it
it's not just about economics communism
it's about having a one-party state
about outlawing
any thought that that you disagree with
and i'm telling you you know these books
white fragility
uh kenny's book uh a raving racist
uh tony heasy coates also won a national
book award
for a disgusting book on race
he's a rabid racist who hates america
and america is too damn tolerant that
that's the reality at this point in time
you